[Music]
i don't really
like kraft mac and cheese so i'm a
little bit nervous
i was always sick as a child so my
comfort food was kraft mac and cheese so
i love this i always got freaked out by
the powder it's like why is it so orange
that's not real cheese the fact that
there's like a single
macaroni and cheese on the label makes
me think that
there's a golden one if i find the right
one maybe i'll be taken to the van
lewin's factory
i'm a bit scared of what this is going
to bring me i'm a little bit afraid
i'm not nervous about the ice cream i'm
nervous about climate change
it's very hot i would love some ice
cream right now like hand it over
a spoon oh yes thank you it's so orange
it's actually not as orange as i thought
it would be i think it could be oranger
when i think of a good mac and cheese i
think of like you added like extra
powder to the mac and cheese
you know it's just food allegedly it's
safe to eat i'm a little scared
but i'm gonna do it i'm ready to go at
it
[Music]
science has gone too far i can't believe
they've done this
what the [ __ ] okay
i i don't know how i feel i love mac and
cheese so like
how does that taste exactly like kraft
mac and cheese
on the first bite it tastes like ice
cream and then like right afterwards it
tastes like kraft mac and cheese
so i'm having a very weird like
cognitive dissonance moment where i'm
like this is definitely ice cream
but yet it is also mac and cheese it's
not terrible
wait this is this is good i'm trying to
think of when
you would want to experience this
because it's a very unique taste
first date maybe not too risky second
date
somehow they they bottled the essence of
kraft mac and cheese but made it taste
like it should be an ice cream and then
put it in that
and i am scared but i'm also intrigued
the more i eat the less
i like it i'm just really hot at this
point so i'm like i need something to
cool me down
it's a little salty a little sweet i
could mix this with noodles
it would just taste like i was eating
crab i almost wish there was
like a single noodle in there because i
feel like that would be a very welcome
surprise
if you really like kraft mac and cheese
you're going to like this ice cream
but i don't so i don't really like the
ice cream
also i would never eat this again like
no
i would absolutely eat this again this
abomination that was created by merging
two
delicious things has created for once
something beautiful
and i am i am pleased do i get to finish
this
yeah go for it and i want
real ice cream like actual ice cream
that is not mac and cheese
yes
[Music]